le patriarche de l'église catholique
chaldéenne se félicite de cette visite
du pape françois le cardinal louis
raphaël premier sac aux appels à une
citoyenneté basée sur la constitution
pour les chrétiens d'orient
déjà le ayatollahs a fait un une
initiative très belle donc sur un poster
il a écrit vous c'est à dire le pape les
chrétiens vous êtes une partie du nord
et nous nous sommes répartis de vaud
donc c'est peut-être le même sens que le
pape et utilise des nous tous nous son
frère le vocabulaire est différent mais
le sens et lui même nous attendons un
changement de mentalité des cultures
respect de la vie respect de lait des
autres avec une signature de citoyenneté
basée sur la constitution a dit
sectarisme pas de marginalisation et pas
d'injustice